[Music]
now you do spend a lot of time in our
games looking at your stats your items
and more so we put a lot of emphasis on
making this entertaining but also making
it come alive on the screen your various
items we do have a layered armor system
now there are holotapes you can listen
to and some of these are even game tapes
[Applause]
[Music]
we like all kinds of games
yeah we we just you know the pip-boy is
an important part of Fallout and we
loved it so much we made a real one so
[Applause]
this comes with our collector's edition
so it is the fallout for pip-boy edition
and yes you could put your phone in it
and yes we made an app for it
so it works with the game and yes it's a
second screen experience and usually I
find second string experiences they're
generally just stupid gimmicks but like
as far as stupid gimmicks goes Irish is
the best [ __ ] one I have ever seen
I'm gonna show it to you in action it
works it actually works perfectly it's
the same code that we use on the Pip Boy
running on the app works on any platform
on your local Wi-Fi Xbox one ps4 PC
of course if you don't get the pip-boy
edition it'll obviously still work on
your smartphone or tablet it's going to
be iOS and Android and will come out
when the game comes out
[Applause]
you